my girlfriend she's getting a heart
transplant and then I found out she's
getting a kidney transplant am I
responsible for her medical bills how
long has she been your girlfriend number
one 20 years 20 20
years yeah okay if I had a friend I'm
thinking of I have a particular friend
in my mind just a friend a buddy of mine
okay a guy that I grew up with if that
dude lived with me for 20 years yeah was
just my my my ride or die friend
and he had to go to the hospital and
have just a complete transmission change
right yeah I would I I not obligation
but as my brother I would participate in
helping where I could I I'm I'm struck
by your
question yeah because she is your wife
you can call it what you want she's your
wife you've been together for 20 years
living together